meantime pets are a beloved part of
anyone's family but as a victim escapes
an abuser that pet can get left behind
bianca holman shares a new program at
safeness to keep furry friends
close by safeness is a haven for those
seeking refuge from domestic violence in
clark county
now the non-profit is able to do more
safeness expanded shelter services to
include on-site pet boarding
for cats and dogs and the idea of you
know uprooting your children and getting
them into shelter well be it the safe
place
having to leave that pet behind is just
an another unbearable thing that that
children may have to leave behind
almost 65 percent of domestic violence
victims are unable to leave their abuser
because they're concerned about what
will happen to their pet
when they leave that's according to safe
place for pets
and 71 percent of victims report their
pets are also being abused
oftentimes the batterer will use the pet
as a manipulation tactic
threatening to kill the pet if the
significant other leaves
having the family dog or cat in the
shelter has an impact on the victim
seeing clients connect around a pet and
be in the pet area and start chatting
together and kids start playing together
and animals start playing together
it's just the right environment for
healing the pet program
includes two stand-alone housing units
with air conditioner and heat
with several dog and cat kennels safene
has also installed a shaded fenced
dog play area let's create an
environment where those fleeing domestic
violence
have as many of the barriers removed for
that as possible because
they deserve to be able to have a path
that's filled with
options and dignity just like anybody
else bianca holman
eight news now well safe nest is hosting
a summer event on july 24th the soiree
will help raise money for future
programming